il perdono un sentimento celebrato da
millenni da filosofi teologi e leader
religiosi spesso descritto come un atto
nobile umanitario capace di elevare
moralmente lo spirito dell'uomo
eppure così difficile da sentire
specialmente quando il responsabile si è
reso colpevole di atti gravi che non
possono e non devono essere giustificati
o dimenticati nei prossimi minuti
vorrei parlarvi delle origini di questo
sentimento e rivelarvi in che modo credo
possa e debba essere sviluppato anche
quando la gravità della situazione può
renderlo difficile e controverso perché
penso che il perdono debba essere
sviluppato
sicuramente abbiamo tutti vissuto
l'esperienza di essere trattati
ingiustamente qualche volta magari siamo
stati abbandonati da un caro amico nel
momento del bisogno oppure traditi da
una persona che amava molto come ci
siamo sentiti in quel momento
probabilmente la tristezza la rabbia e
il risentimento hanno iniziato a
tormentarci e magari abbiamo anche
iniziato a desiderare di vendicarci
contro chi ci ha ferito che hanno
danneggiato però questi sentimenti le
persone che ci hanno fatto del male
oppure soltanto noi stessi e su questa
domanda che vorrei riflettere con voi
oggi perché sono convinta che come disse
una volta il grande scrittore americano
mark twain
la rabbia è un acido che può provocare
più danno al contenitore che la
custodisce che a qualsiasi oggetto sul
quale venga versato
ma qual è l'origine della rabbia e se ci
provoca tanto danno come possiamo
superarla ricerche condotte nel campo
della psicologia sociale hanno
dimostrato che la rabbia il risentimento
scaturiscono principalmente dal modo in
cui spieghiamo le azioni di chi ha
fallito
secondo questi studi quando ci troviamo
nella posizione della vittima
tendiamo a dipingere erroneamente chi ci
ha fatto del male come una persona
fondamentalmente cattiva per esempio
l'amico che ci ha abbandonato è
descritto come
tunista il genitore che ci ha fatto un
torto come un egoista e il nostro marito
e nostra moglie che ci ha tradito come
un infedele
al contrario però quando siamo stati noi
a tradire o qualcuno o a ferire qualcuno
in qualche modo in genere tendiamo a
dipingere le nostre azioni come
risultato di accadimenti esterni e
circostanze al di là del nostro
controllo
per esempio ci giustifichiamo dicendo
che la nostra è stata soltanto una
reazione al comportamento negativo
dell'altro
oppure che in quel momento eravamo sotto
stress o che stiamo attraversando un
periodo difficile
la ricerca dimostra quindi che le
persone tendono ad attribuire
erroneamente il comportamento degli
altri ha caratteristiche fisse della
loro personalità e il proprio
comportamento e circostanze esterne
gli esperti chiamano questa tendenza
l'errore di attribuzione la mia idea è
che se vogliamo lasciare andare la
rabbia e risentimento che ostacolano lo
sviluppo del perdono
dobbiamo correggere l'errore di
attribuzione secondo questa idea quindi
l'errore di attribuzione è uno dei
principali ostacoli al perdono e la
causa di molti conflitti che ci tengono
separati l'uno dall'altro sia a livello
individuale che a livello collettivo
a livello individuale queste tendenze
portano a una separazione concettuale
tra il sé el'altro l'altro diviene il
sito delle nostre proiezioni negative
viene rappresentato come qualcosa di
diverso dal se comune entità separata
che non merita rispetto
faranno i nostri sentimenti e sfidando i
nostri valori
l'altro perde la sua dignità di essere
umano e può essere quindi trattato di
conseguenza a livello collettivo
queste tendenze psicologiche portano da
un lato a guerre e scontri interminabili
come il conflitto israelo palestinese la
guerra civile in siria e il terrorismo
dall'altro portano la creazione di
sistemi di giustizia eccessivamente
punitivi che prevedono pene carcerarie
severe e prolungate anche per crimini
minori
eppure come dimostrano gli altissimi
livelli di recidiva registrati tra i
condannati in vari paesi del mondo
queste misure punitive non sono in grado
né di trasformare il comportamento dei
trasgressori medi porre fine ai
conflitti sociali e creare un mondo più
sicuro
allora forse dovremmo chiederci la
punizione del carcere sono davvero gli
unici sistemi a nostra disposizione per
fare giustizia
esiste forse una maniera alternativa in
effetti esiste una strada alternativa
una strada che sfida le nostre idee
prestabilite su come gli individui e la
società dovrebbero rispondere alla
violenza al conflitto
secondo questa idea se l'obiettivo è di
portare pace e armonia nella nostra
società
i trasgressori devono essere aiutati a
sviluppare l'empatia verso le loro
vittime ea capire il danno che le loro
azioni hanno provocato a loro volta le
vittime devono essere aiutate a
sviluppare la compassione e il perdono
verso i trasgressori
nonostante la difficoltà della
situazione ma perché le vittime
dovrebbero aspirare a perdonare chi gli
ha fatto del male
la ricerca psicologica ha dimostrato che
trasformare la rabbia e risentimento in
compassione perdono contribuisce
positivamente al benessere psicologico e
alla salute fisica delle vittime del
processo
i sostenitori del modello tradizionale
di giustizia sostengono però che
perdonare chi ha commesso un crimine è
irrispettoso nei confronti del dolore
della vittima e dei valori della società
a mio avviso però queste crisi che si
basano su un'idea della relazione tra il
trasgressore è l'atto criminale che non
riconosce la fondamentale
giustificazione morale del perdono
infatti mentre il sistema tradizionale
tende a identificare il peccato col
peccatore per riuscire a perdonare senza
però giustificare dobbiamo separare
l'atto criminale che può essere
condannato dalla persona responsabile di
tale atto che può invece essere
perdonata condannando il crimine ma non
la persona
da un lato manteniamo intatto
il rispetto per il dolore della vittima
e i valori della società e dall'altra
aiutiamo il trasgressore a non
identificarsi con il suo errore e la
vittima a perdonare il suo malfattore è
sostenendo la separazione concettuale
tra il crimine la persona che il ruolo
del sistema giudiziario può risultare
determinante per lo sviluppo del perdono
ma il nostro sistema giudiziario è in
grado di sostenere questa separazione
concettuale nel modello retributivo
tradizionale l'equilibrio della bilancia
della giustizia si ottiene infliggendo
una punizione al trasgressore
commisurata al danno sociale provocato
dal crimine secondo alcuni critici
focalizzandosi esclusivamente
sull'azione da compiere nei confronti
del trasgressore
il modello tradizionale tende ignorare i
bisogni delle vittime nel processo
infatti privando le vittime di una voce
nel procedimento
il sistema penale tende a negare loro la
possibilità di esprimere i propri
sentimenti e le proprie paure e di
superare così il trauma provocato dall
evento per risolvere questo problema
questi critici propongono un modello
alternativo di giustizia basato sulla
riparazione del danno provocato dal
crimine alle vittime e alla società
anziché sulla quantità di punizione da
imporre al trasgressore
ci sono vari metodi per implementare
questo modello ma quello che sicuramente
ha avuto più successo è la conferenza e
para ti va la conferenza riparativa
cerca di riunire le vittime i
trasgressori e i loro familiari per
trovare insieme una soluzione
costruttiva ai danni provocati dal
crimine aiutati da un mediatore
imparziale in genere un agente di
polizia mentre il sistema tradizionale
si basa su una relazione antagonistica
dallo stato i trasgressori
le conferenze riparative cercano di
creare una relazione di cooperazione tra
tutte le parti coinvolte in una dinamica
di carattere circolare
la mia idea è che mentre approccio
antagonistico del sistema tradizionale
raramente stimola il condannato a
chiedere scusa e le vittime per donare
la natura cooperativa e circolare della
conferenza riparativa crea l'ambiente
ideale affinché avvenga questo scambio
questa idea si basa su una serie di
studi condotti in australia e nuova
zelanda che hanno dimostrato le
straordinarie potenzialità trasformative
di questo modello come abbiamo visto per
esempio per riuscire a perdonare la
vittima deve riuscire a separare
identità del criminale dal suo
comportamento
per esempio identificando le circostanze
esterne che possono aver contribuito
alle sue azioni
gli studi australiani e neozelandesi
dimostrano che la maggioranza delle
conferenze riparative sono in grado di
sostenere questa separazione concettuale
infatti quasi il 70 per cento delle
vittime intervistate in nuova zelanda
descrivevano il trasgressore con una
persona fondamentalmente buona che aveva
però compiuto un'azione sbagliata mentre
le vittime intervistati in australia
raramente disapprovavano il trasgressore
come persona
d'altro canto come abbiamo visto per
riuscire a chiedere scusa
i trasgressori devono riuscire a
sviluppare l'empatia verso le loro
vittime ea capire il danno che le loro
azioni hanno provocato gli studi
australiani dimostrano anche le
conferenze riparative sono più efficaci
dei processi penali tradizionali nel
facilitare questo tipo di trasformazione
infatti mentre nei processi penali
tradizionali soltanto il 19 per cento
delle vittime riportava deve ricevuto
delle scuse nelle conferenze riparative
queste percentuali schizzano al 72 per
cento
questo dato è particolarmente
significativo perché la ricerca ha
dimostrato che le vittime sono molto più
inclini a perdonare quando ricevono
delle scuse
come possiamo anche immaginare
infine gli studi
riuscirà a perdonare le vittime devono
riuscire a lasciare andare la rabbia ea
sviluppare la compassione verso i
trasgressori è ancora una volta gli
studi condotti in australia dimostrano
l'efficacia della giustizia riparativa
per sostenere questa trasformazione
musica
infatti mentre prima delle conferenze
riparative il 63 per cento delle vittime
provava a rabbia verso il trasgressore
dopo le conferenze queste percentuali si
dimezzano calando drasticamente al 29
per cento
viceversa se prima delle conferenze
riparative soltanto il 19 per cento
delle vittime provava compassione verso
il trasgressore
dopo le conferenze queste percentuali
raddoppiano raggiungendo il 48 per cento
come dimostrano questi studi quindi si è
completata con successo una conferenza
riparativa può contribuire alla
creazione di una nuova relazione tra la
vittima e il criminale e col tempo
portare al perdono e alla
riconciliazione
alcuni critici sostengono però che la
giustizia riparativa è basata su idee un
po ingenue e utopistiche esse infatti
zano l'egoismo che pervade molte
relazioni sociali sostenendo che queste
smentiscono la fiducia nelle dosi
empatiche dell'uomo su cui si basa a
questo modello per ricerca psicologica e
sperimentale dimostra però che se
trattiamo le persone in modo onesto
queste saranno a loro volta più inclini
a comportarsi in modo onesto se le
trattiamo come se fossero affidabili
queste saranno a loro volta che
affidabili e se diamo loro una
responsabilità attiva queste la
assumeranno in maniera costruttiva
fidarsi della capacità umana all'empatia
non è quindi ingenuità ma una scelta
basata su un accurata osservazione dei
dati a nostra disposizione
la giustizia riparativa non è neanche
una proposta turistica
anzi questo modello è oggi è sviluppato
in vari paesi anglosassoni come gli
stati uniti e l'inghilterra in paesi
devastati dalla guerra guerra civile
mela ruanda e in varie altre parti del
mondo tra cui anche l'italia
nonostante questi progressi però siamo
ancora a uno stato embrionale
il sistema giudiziario è oggi più che
mai pieno di problemi
per esempio come molti probabilmente
sanno negli ultimi anni abbiamo
assistito a una crescita esponenziale
nel numero di carcerati e altissimi
livelli di ricaduta dopo il rilascio
etichettando i trasgressori come
criminali
abbiamo di fatto spinti a identificarsi
con le loro azioni impedendo ogni
possibilità di cambiamento al contrario
se riusciamo a separare l'identità del
criminale dalle sue azioni ea ripensare
che cos'è la giustizia che cosa vogliamo
ottenere attraverso il suo utilizzo
possiamo creare un modello alternativo
che miri non tanto all'inflazione della
pena
quanto al benessere e alla maturazione
di tutte le parti coinvolte vittime
trasgressori e collettività
fino ad oggi ci siamo sempre chiesti
quanta punizione dovremmo infliggere per
questo crimine e se invece iniziassimo a
chiederci che cosa possiamo fare per
ristabilire l'armonia perduta
grazie